to present the award for best song here
is a young woman of astounding
versatility an unbound talent who makes
every song the best miss Barbara
Streisand
well congratulations Barbara on starting
your movie career I I hear you finish
funny girl and are about to start Hello
Dolly that's five well that's a good
gird you get a couple more quick e's
like that under your belt you'll be
ready to do a really big one with me is
that a promise that's a threat ah the
five nominees for the best song are
Terry Gill Kissin for the bare
necessities Quincy Jones and Bob Russell
for the eyes of love Burt Bacharach and
Hal David for the look of now Leslie
Brooke us for talk to the animals and
James Van Deusen Sammy Kahn for
Thoroughly Modern Millie
the winner is Leslie Griffis or talk to
the animals
excepting for Leslie Britta's Sammy
Davis Leslie and Evie and the littlest
brick assist of all they're busy working
now but I know that Leslie would want me
to thank the members of the Academy for
the other and if I may to say Leslie
would probably say it's absolutely
marvelous it's super thank you god bless
you
you